everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we are in round 3 of
our coverage of the 2017 grand prix from
geneva our competitors today whites
going to be played by payal Leonov he is
from the Ukraine currently ranked 19th
in the world first two round so far he
has a win and a loss he didn't play in
the first tournament so he still has
this tournament and the next one to put
up a good result he is still in
contention to be in one of the top two
players at the end of the Grand Prix so
excited to see him play so we don't get
to see him too often
his opponent playing the black pieces
Yana fonyód currently ranked 17th in the
world he's got a contention
mathematically as far as getting in the
top two he's played in the first two
legs of the Grand Prix when we play in
the last one but all in all he's still
playing for both a higher rating and
there's money on the line even if you're
not on the top two there's still a lot
to be playing for he's more known for
rapid and blitz probably one of the top
three players in the world and rapid in
blitz always puts up tough competition
in those tournaments but all-in-all very
strong competitor so we're going to get
started white starts out with pawn to e4
pawn to c5 so the sicilian events we
don't see the sicilian defence as much
anymore which you know sim can be
somewhat surprising knowing is how well
the sicilian defence plays especially at
the highest levels nice f3 upon d6 pawn
d4 so kind of normal lines that you
would see and then after Knight to c3 we
get pawn to a6 this is getting into the
night Dorf defense really one of the the
top lines in the Sicilian defense it
blocks off this critical square here on
b5 which the bishop would like to come
to Bishop to b5 check potentially the
knight to b5 Black has some ideas here
he later on might want to play pawn here
too to e5 they push forward with pawn to
b5 then activating his LightSquared
Bishop start to really have an advantage
on the Queen side of the board he can
get his rook over here to c8 control the
semi open file that's kind of what
blacks going to be looking for in the
knight Dorf the fence
white has a few options from here you
can continue
with the main line which is disappear to
g5 then play pawn to f4 I decided to go
for a little quieter move this was a
little bit more aggressive black playing
the Sicilian offense many times is an
aggressive line you may look at and say
that he hasn't really extended his
pieces too far but he has a pre
aggressive setup once he starts to
account our attack started pushing
forward with his pawns getting his minor
pieces of almond to the game so white a
lot of times will counter this with
their own aggression a white decides in
this particular game to play a little
quieter and play Bishop to e2 getting
ready to castle on the Kings side not
really extend his pieces and play that
pawn to f4 which is pretty aggressive
from White's point of view now pawn to
e5 like also had the option of pawn to
e6 but I decided to continue with the
main ideas of the knight Dorf defense
when you do see this a pawn to e5 it is
important to note that the pawn on d6 is
a backward pawn and sometimes can be
difficult for black to hold on to white
towards the middle and getting into the
endgame will start to kind of attack
this square and black has to use some of
his minor pieces sometimes or even a
rook to kind of defend this pawn here on
d6 so white kicks his back Knight back
here to b3 Bishop here to e7 getting
ready to castle on the King side Bishop
to e3 had some options he still could
play this Bishop to g5 but after we saw
Bishop to e2 more of the quiet game no
one really expected the bishop to come
beyond III so it does want to continue
his development but does not want to
bring out Bishop to g5 knowing the best
kind not the game plan he's been going
with now Bishop to e6 did have the
option of pushing forward with his pawn
to b5 trying to bring his fish appear to
be 7 but decides and says to go ahead
and bring it here to e6 start to attack
this night here on b3 now Knight to d5 -
saying hey if you want to exchange in
the center of the board that's fine with
me
this does open up this pawn here on e4
for the Knights I would recommend not
taking this and you don't see that in
the game if the knight were to take here
on e4 it gets very tricky with Bishop to
b6 the Queen check that I like to call
it Queen's kind of in a tough spot if
you can look at and say well you can go
to sea
eight or d7 will kind of look at both
look at the worst move first which would
be Queen to d7
because now Knight to c7 check forking
the rook here on a8 after the King were
to move you don't want to move it here
to d7 or d8 because that would be a
discovered attack after Knight - aah
that would be checked so after King to
f8 that's kind of a terrible spot in
general because the rooks kind of
trapped here on h8 for a while we see
the knight take on a ace and this Knight
can't really go anywhere productive if
he were to come to c6 okay that's fine
that I can still come back here to c7
he's going to be safe this was a little
bit worse than if you were to let's say
play Queen to c8 still going to see the
same night to c7 check fork but now
after King to f8 we see a capture now
that I can come here to d7 which the
Queen was in d7 before this is attacking
the bishop on b6 so the knight can't
just freely come back here because that
would fall so maybe aside from here just
go and bring the bishop back here to II
III lose his knight but he did get that
rook and he also kind of stopped his
opponent from developing his major piece
here on h8 and the King is no longer
able to castle so all in all it's
definitely not going to be the best
recommendation to take a with his night
here on e4 but he decides to go ahead
and play Knight to d7 now if you kind of
look at this without looking at what
would happen if the knight takes on e4
this may look like a simple development
move but it does more than that the
knight on d7 is actually attacking this
pawn on e4 because we just looked at now
the knight can freely take on a4 doesn't
have to worry about the bishop coming
down to a b6 just because the knight can
take that right away so white has to
kind of respond what just looks like a
development move and he responds with
Queen to d3 and this is protecting this
pawn here on e4 so these are some of the
what's nice about the Sicilian defense
especially the knight or if there's a
lot of theory that goes into this so
players have been playing these lines
for for many many years and to kind of
looked at these situations but for
someone that may not be familiar with
some of the deep lines in the night or
offense this is
of the stuff that they think about and
if you're playing in your own game you
want to make sure that you look at and
so you know what you know why would he
play Knight to d5 why is he not taking
this pawn and kind of how do I respond
if he plays Knight to d7 if you don't
see that Queen to b3 then you can start
to gobble up material here on e4 since
you are protected black but from blacks
point of view decides to go ahead and
castle on the King side and then pawn up
here to a four could have played a
little bit more I would say draw lush if
you will
magnus carlsen just earlier this year
played castle on the Kings side it was
very easy for black to go ahead and draw
in this game white decides to go and
play for a little bit more aggressive
line and plays pawn here to a4 and then
the bishop captures on d5 we start to
see an exchange in the center of the
board Knight down here to a c5 after the
exchange then pawn up here to c4
solidifying this pawn on d5 this is now
a protected past pawn and this is one of
the things that White's going to be
looking to do in this game he does have
the paired Bishop right here he will be
looking to push this pawn up further in
the game he still has the option to
castling on either side of the board
casting on the Kings side is a little
bit safer but we started to see him
shift his approach from a kind of
conservative opening now going with this
pawn to a4 he definitely has the option
now of castling on the king or queen
side and then throwing everything he can
at his opponent's king side the board
definitely would be very aggressive
black continues with Queens to c7 used
to be more of a pawn to e4 but the meta
shifted to a queen to c7 Queen down here
c2 allows him to just protect more of
these pawns on board you can now protect
the pawn on b2 and a4 which wasn't able
to before and that allows him if he
wants to castle on the Queen side to get
his rook over to the kings of the board
not have to worry about protecting that
with his rook on a1 pawn to g4 and that
signals to everyone that okay we're
going to have a strong attack here we've
moved away from our passive just kind of
wait and see we are now getting into the
castle in the Queens I throw everything
out our opponent we have the doubled
bishops start to align those at the key
side of the board from black black on
the other hand wants to kind of see if
he has any room to kind of get around he
can has a nice little outpost here on d4
if he can get there he has the bishop in
the Queen he can line up and start to
attack his opponent but he wants to make
sure that he still has a pretty strong
defense in front of his king because
White's going to be coming for him pawn
to e4 castle on the Queen said the board
fishes e6 from the stuff we talked about
pawn to g5 forcing the knight to move
knight comes back here to d7 King to be
one wants to get off this dark square
diagonal with the bishop
it's a little bit safer here on b1 night
down here a 5 and then pawn to h4 as we
talked about pushing everything on the
King side of the board Knight down here
to f3 attacking his pawn on h4 and then
rook to h3 I'm not really sure that the
rook to h3 does too much he's not going
to exchange material here on f3 give up
as a rook for Knight he's not going to
be doing that and besides that that this
Knights not really doing anything too
much right now instead I were to just
play pawn to a trot continuing with the
same game plan as before decides to play
rook here to h3 Queen to d7 attacking
the rook rook comes back here at h1 kind
of seems like a wasted move from white
my opinion Queen to e7
and now pawn to h5 is no longer an
option because then I can just come back
here to g5 Bishop can take is now it's
protected by the Queen so I think you
had an opportunity to just extend a
little bit with this pressure
decided not to instead decides to go
ahead and take with his Bishop here on
f3 that's kind of a nuisance with the
outpost with a knight on f3 says let's
go and get rid of that I'm going to just
open up the board a little bit more so
pawn takes here on f3 and then pawn to
h5 black looks at the board Satan says
let's attack on the Queen side of the
board since you're going to focus over
here on the King side and Y could
continue on the Kings side of the board
if you wanted to instead decided to
worry about the Queen side a little bit
so we do see some exchange on board a
queen over here to d7 attacking the pawn
queen to d3 still centralizing the Queen
getting it along this D file as well as
protecting the square here on b5
rook over here to b8
another attacker on the square to be
five and then the white says okay let's
continue with our game playing pawn to
h6 and then pawn here to g6 but this
does start to take away some of the
squares that the black King can go to
Bishop down here to d2 and then after
the rook takes then the bishop is going
to come here to c3 very strong attack
can eventually bring it here to g7 if
you wanted to work down here to b3
we're cover here Eve one queen g4 so
both sides starting to put a lot of
pressure on each other a lot of crazy
situations that they could get into a
recover to e4 and this is where it gets
all interesting this is a pretty crazy
move for white saying I'm okay giving up
some material with the exchange I really
want to focus on this pawn here on d5
and so black says okay first I got to
get my Queen out of the way and then we
start to see clean over here to f3
Bishop to e5 and this is where the plan
continues with rook taking on e5 giving
up his rook here on e5 in exchange for
that Bishop so the Queen takes and then
pawn pushes forward to d6 so we look at
it as far as materials concern black is
winning in this game but black does have
to worry about this pawn pushing for
date anytime you have a passed pawn rule
number one is pushed that pawn rules
number two through five are referred to
rule number one we see pawn to f6 and
then pawn to a d7 and as far as what you
know black really has to do here first
he needs to go ahead and take the bishop
right here after the Queen takes the
Queen really needs to go ahead and take
this Queen right here on c3 he could
easily take it pawn recaptures Black has
more pawns on board you can bring us
fruit over here to d8 you can eventually
bring his King to e7 have an exchange on
board he's going to be fine at the end
of the day this is an in-game I think
you could draw potentially win I think
he decides to get a little bit too
greedy and play Queen to e7 I don't he
calculated the in game as much as the
could have and we see Queen here to be
three maybe this is the movie didn't see
maybe which we'll get to in a minute
this pawn here on f2 is what he did not
think about but there's no real good
move for black in this situation you
can't move his Queen to block it I can't
really move his rook to block it because
then just pawn pushing forward to d8
getting a queen and check that's going
to be bad with the rook back here on d1
protecting that so King over here - HHI
the only move and then Queen to d5 is a
very very tricky trigger spot the pawns
threatening pushing forward also
attacking the pawn here on c5 rook to d8
does stop that but then after rook to d3
then black is forced to resign in the
game sometimes people always say well
you know this doesn't look like a in
game very easy for y to win how would
this continue and the biggest thing to
keep in mind is that the rook could come
here to e3 so for example who is the
pawn to g5 which makes a lot of sense
then you could easily just see rook to
e3 threatening this Queen there's no
real good square for the Queen to go to
and as soon as he comes off his mark
then the rook can eventually come here
to be eight but first you could see
Queen to c6 this kind of adds another
attacker not only to this d7 squared but
more importantly this e8 Square so now
when their work comes up here going to
have an exchange and black is going to
lose that White's going to be up
material also going to be threatening
this pawn here on c5 so we see Queen
down here to h6 trying to gobble up
material rook up here e8 all in all this
is going to be extremely bad for for
black so that's what black saw on board
didn't see any way around that Sofia
today decided to resign so
congratulations to PI you will he has
two wins currently in the tournament so
that is definitely good if you didn't
have the last loss you know he would be
at the top of the leaderboard but all in
all having a very good tournament so far
still in contention
for both top two and a good payday at
the end of this tournament so thank you
guys for watching a round three and we
will be back tomorrow for round number
four